des toilettes publiques devenu un lieu
de commémoration
le 14 septembre dernier une employée de
métro a été ici poignardée à mort ce
meurtre a choqué le pays chaque jour des
Sud-Coréens dépose des fleurs et des
messages de soutien comme cette
étudiante à l'université
ce qui me rend vraiment furieuse c'est
le fait que le gouvernement insiste que
ce n'était pas un féminicide mais l'acte
d'un individu que c'était juste un
incident malheureux
pour le ministre de l'Égalité des genres
ce n'est pas un crime misogyne une
déclaration qui a mis le feu aux poudres
car pour beaucoup il s'agit bien d'un
modèle de féminicide c'est-à-dire d'un
meurtre parce que la victime était une
femme depuis 3 ans le suspect la
poursuivait de messages de visite
incessantes il l'a menaçait soi-disant
par amour il avait même placé une petite
caméra dans les toilettes du métro pour
la filmer à son insu un voyeurisme
digital fréquent dans ce pays ultra
connecté
je suis toujours un peu inquiète quand
je vois des petits trous dans les murs
des toilettes je me demandais est-ce que
ce n'est pas une caméra beaucoup de
jeunes femmes pensent comme moi j'ai
même une amie qui n'utilise que les
toilettes qu'elle a bien vérifié
à l'extérieur de la station Kimi eux
rejoint un groupe de féministes
plusieurs semaines après le crime des
activistes continuent à clamer leur
colère
le gouvernement conservateur qui ne
ferait pas assez pour protéger les
femmes il souhaite supprimer le
ministère de l'Égalité des genres alors
que les affaires se multiplient en 2016
déjà un autre meurtre dans le métro
avait enflammé le pays
je sais que vous avez l'impression
d'être abandonné que jamais rien ne
change mais je voulais vous dire ne
perdons pas espoir
il y a un nom une nouvelle loi a rendu
le harcèlement passible de 3 ans de
prison contre une amende maximale de 80
€ par mois
[Musique]
depuis le nombre de cas signalés a été
multiplié par 6 mais les activistes
rappellent que dans ce genre d'affaires
les plaintes sont très rares
cette victime n'a eu ni l'envie ni le
courage d'appeler les autorités il y a
un an une rencontre d'abord anodines
avec un homme se transforme en cauchemar
presque tous les jours il l'appelle et
passe la voir sur son lieu de travail
une boulangerie un peu comme celle-ci il
veut la convaincre de le laisser la
raccompagner chez elle il veut sortir
avec elle
je lui ai dit de ne pas venir mais il
continuait à passer à mon travail il
m'appelait souvent il n'écoutait pas ce
que je lui disais donc je ne savais plus
quoi faire
elle doit parfois demander à son frère
de fermer la boulangerie à sa place sa
mère est obligée d'utiliser les caméras
de vidéosurveillance pour la surveiller
comme beaucoup de victimes elle ne pense
pas que la police la protégera il y a
deux mois soir a fini par arrêter
ce qui aurait été le plus inquiétant
pour moi c'est que je dépose une plainte
et qu'il la prenne
alors oui j'aurais eu peur de sa
réaction
il faut vraiment y réfléchir à deux fois
avant de faire ça aujourd'hui j'ai
encore peur qu'il débarque de nouveau
son prévenir il sait toujours où je
travaille
selon les activistes le problème
principal de la loi actuelle et que le
harcèlement ne peut être condamné sans
le consentement express des victimes
cela encourage les suspects à harceler
encore davantage leur proie pour qu'elle
retire leur plaintes les injonctions
d'éloignement sont-elles rares et pas
toujours efficaces
cette directrice d'un refuge pour femme
pense toutefois qu'un nouveau changement
de loi n'est pas la priorité
on pourrait déjà faire beaucoup plus si
les lois existantes étaient appliquées
correctement la police et les procureurs
devraient développer leur connaissance
et leur sensibilité sur cette question
du harcèlement
les gens pensaient que suivre une femme
dans la rue ou faire preuve d'un
comportement obsessif était juste une
façon d'exprimer une passion romantique
et cette idée est toujours partagée par
beaucoup
[Musique]
seulement environ 1% des harcèlements
signalés débouches sur des arrestations
le gouvernement a promis des peines plus
sévères mais les activistes craignent
que les menaces sans éducation ne
permettent pas un vrai changement des
mentalités